What would happen if we designate you to humanity's most powerful nuclear weapon
at the deepest point of the ocean?
For sure.
So now miss hundreds of meters high would destroy coastal cities.
Earthquakes would level countries.
New volcanoes would bring us nuclear winter,
maybe even earth could be ripped apart or thrown out of orbit.
Wow.
Almost currently earth deepest known point is inside the Mariana trench.
The Mariana trench is a very deep valley right at the edge of two tectonic
plates that looks like an upside down mountain.
It reaches a depth of about 11 kilometers,
almost at three times deeper than the dark grave of the titanic.
It's one of the last places on earth for humans to explore,
pitch black and under a thousand atmospheres of pressure.
It's a relatively pristine environment,
thanks to the absence of humans.
A great case for our nuclear task.
We'll use the most powerful nuclear bomb humans have ever exploded.
The rds to 20 hydrogen bomb or Sar Bomba,
it's explosion was so massive that it's shockwave traveled around the earth
three times and it's mushroom cloud stretched 56 kilometers into the sky.
It's shockwave was strong enough to destroy everything and a thousand square
kilometers.
It's fireball,
hot enough to burn the rubble bombs like this release.
It's such an enormous amount of energy at once that they could boil away an
entire leg and if we set off a nuclear bomb in the Mariana trench,
that's exactly what happens.
Let's pull the trigger
and the first few microseconds,
the nuclear fuel undergoes its chain reaction and explodes with the power of 50
megatons of TNT.
A blinding flash of light illuminates the darkness of the trench.
For the first time in history,
the he's of the explosion produces eight cavity,
a flaming bubble of water vapor,
radioactive nuclei,
and the remains of very unlucky fish.
The bubble grows quickly as it vaporizes the water around it.
The pressure of the bubble is immense.
Plowing outwards as if there's nothing in the way.
Sending off a shockwave that will be felt by seismic stations and whales around
the world,
and then almost as fast as it emerges,
it stops on the surface of the earth.
This fireball bubble would grow to 10 kilometers.
The second data,
it's detonated as the atmosphere batty puts up a fight to hold it back,
but the pressure at the bottom of the Mariana trench is enormous with 11
kilometers of water overhead being in the Mariana trench as link being crushed
by a hydraulic press from every direction here,
a second after the detonation out bubble is about a kilometer across.
When oddly enough,
it starts to shrink.
The bubble itself losing pressure as it expands until the water turns it back.
We compressing it.
The tug of war between the fiery death bubble and water goes back and forth a
few times.
The bubble shrinking and growing until eventually the bubble loses for good.
The pressure around it is too great and turbulent water begins to chop it up.
It becomes something like the underwater equivalent of a mushroom cloud as it
disintegrates into many smaller hot and radioactive bubbles drifting upwards and
as our mighty destructive blast rises to the surface,
it does basically nothing.
Just a small wave and a bubbling plume of radioactive will.
Water in the Pacific notes to Nami will wash away Japan or California,
although boats and whales in the area might have a bad time.
The radioactive fallout will be diluted into the Pacific after a few days,
although a fair amount of radioactive water and salt makes it to the atmosphere
where it collects and then rains down again.
Even if the wind blows the fallout directly towards the Philippines.
The worst event probably happens over the oceans,
but clearly the real danger comes from our explosion triggering earthquakes and
volcanoes,
right?
Even if we designated the bomb right in the trench at the exact point where
tectonic plates touch,
probably not the explosion would vaporize a part of the sea floor and turned a
lot of sand into glass,
but most of the energy goes into the water,
not seismic waves.
Earthquakes are already quite common at tectonic plate boundaries and
earthquakes with as much seismic energy as our bomb happened a few times a year
without triggering any sort of apocalypse,
but maybe it will affect the Earth's orbit since no masses taken away or added
to the earth,
our orbit is completely unaffected.
Also,
there have been well over a thousand nuclear tests in the last 70 years,
and that didn't change our orbis.
So why would this time be different?
The strongest forces humanity can unleash our lovable compared to the forces of
nature.
The planet is too big.
It doesn't care.
So what happens to us if we designate a nuclear weapon really deep in the ocean?
Pretty much nothing.
Okay?
Did you know that every bird in our videos has an owner more than 1000 people
have got their own bird.
It helps us explain things.
Clowns around in the background or dies.
Horrible and avoidable death.
If you want your own bird too,
and you want it to appear in one of our videos,
you can get it at patrion.com/courts Cozart Pete.
Sean is one of the main ways we sustain ourselves.
So on top of getting a super nice Avatar,
you also help us make more and better videos.